bin ich dumm sag mir bitte am Ende von
diesem Video ob ich einfach dumm bin
oder ob ihr das was ich Euch jetzt zeige
auch nicht wusstet wenn ihr Champignons
habt und die in der Pfanne anbratet was
macht ihr normalerweise dazu ich denke
mal Öl oder habe ich auch mein Leben
lang so gemacht bis mir jemand gesagt
hat dass man sie einfach ohne Öl
anbraten kann und das ist eine
unbeschichtete Pfanne normalerweise
brennt alles darin an was nicht 5 Liter
Öl dabei hat vertraut mir alles was wir
brauchen ist Geduld es ist verrückt die
Pfanne bleibt quasi sauber ich habe so
viele Leute gefragt keiner kann das
macht mit dem Trick was ihr wollt wir
machen jetzt ein leckeres Brot
wenn überhaupt sind die Pilze noch
saftiger als sonst krank das ist
wirklich bescheuert immer rein in die
Masse deswegen so gut